the rights of people to privacy over the
use of electronic data in their homes is
set to be bolstered at a meeting in
Luxembourg European Union justice
ministers gave support for more privacy
on the use of electronic information in
households for things like personal
online social media activity the new
rules are aimed at upgrading the you use
data protection system which dates from
1995 but they've been subject to long
debate and some heavy lobbying I'm very
confident that the progress made and the
progress made will be a great benefit to
many millions of European consumers and
to businesses operating in across the
European Union it will provide
additional protection so people's
privacy the one thing that everyone is
agreed upon is that this regulation will
enhance the protections available and
the privacy available during their talks
The ministers focused on the first four
chapters of the draft out of regulation
those sections include general
provisions on personal data principles
governing excuse the rights of people
who studies and accessed and obligations
on those who would use personal
information The ministers also agreed
that European Union institutions will be
afforded the same data protection as
Member States
because parts of the draft regulation
are interlocking no agreement on any
section can be set in stone until the
entire package is agreed